الشعر لسان العرب وكلماته ما تزال منذ
الازل محفوره في تاريخهم ووجدانهم لكن ومع
تقدم الحياه صار واجبا ايجاد قنوات اخرى
اكثر تنوعا لتقديم الشعر شركه ات قدمت ذلك
بالفعل عبر تاسيس منصه شعر في مدينه
الرياض بالسعوديه
كمبادره للتفاعل العام مع الشعر العربي
وتقديمه بصفته مركز واساس الفنون اللغويه
العربيه ليس الشعر فقط بل ايضا تجلياته
الاخرى من موسيقى وغنى وذلك من خلال
تقديمها بسيناريو مسرحي معد مسبقا في
تجربه جديده تتفاعل مع الاجيال الحديثه
المنصه الجديده انطلقت مع بدايه شهر مارس
الجاري مع كوكبه من شعراء الشعر الفصيح
والشعر الشعبي الذين ابدعوا بتقديم
القصائد بصحبه الموسيقى العظمى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من الرياض ينضم لنا الشاعر عبد اللطيف بن
يوسف اهلا بكم سيد عبد اللطيف شكرا على
تواجدكم معنا في صباح العربيه منصه جديده
للشعر تتفاعل معها الاجيال الحديثه كيف
تستوصفون هذه التجربه الجديده الشعريه
[موسيقى]
اولا صباح الخير نادين وسهام
قبل ان اجيبك يمكن من الاشياء اللطيفه ان
يكون
نتحدث اليوم عن الشعر في يوم المراه
العالميه
اعتقد كما ان لا يمكننا ان نفكر في
الثقافه العربيه خارج اطار الشعر فلا
يمكننا ان نفكر في الشعر خارج اطار الانثى
او المراه وكما يقول ابن عربي كل ما لا
يؤنث لا يعول عليه فعلا
بالنسبه للمنصه
طبعا
الفكره هي طبعا
مرتبطه بشكل كبير من فتره طويله
من اول ما بدا لدينا في المملكه هذا النوع
من لنسميه الازدهار الثقافي هذا النوع من
الموجه الجديده من من الثقافه والتنوع
الفني
كان لابد للشعر ان يلعب هذا الدور كما
لعبه في التاريخ يعني عاده ما يعني كان
الشعر يلعب دورا محوريا في ازمنه الازدهار
الثقافي يعني اذا برجع بالذاكره من الزمن
الاندلسي الى يعني في العصر الحديث الى
فتره النهضه العربيه كان للشعر دور في ان
يكون هو هذا الجامع هو هذا الرابط بين
الفنون بانواعها المتعدده سواء
الفنون السمعيه او البصريه او الاشكال
المتعدده للشكل الفني عبد اللطيف اليوم
انت شخص
يا هل لان الشاعر هو حر بصناعه لغته
وبصناعه اسلوبه وطريقته ام ان الوقت
والزمان اصبح
مختلفا عن فكره الكلاسيكيه في طرح الشعر
العربي
سؤال جميل يعني الفكره ان اولا
الحريه شرط الشعر يعني ان صح التعبير لكن
كذلك
المساله انه اليوم لدينا فرصه لان احنا
كشعراء ان نجد روافد وموارد جديده يعني
بمعنى الدخول في مثل هذه النوع من التجارب
الفنيه هو فعليا دخولي الى حقول جديده الى
مناطق للالهام جديده الى فهم او توسيع
للمدارات
بحيث ان تكون انتاجك حتى الشعري الشخصي
يكون اكثر اتساعا غير معزول عن
لنقول الابداع العام الذي يحيط بك في
المجال الفني بشكله الكلي
[موسيقى]
وكمان استاذ عبد اللطيف لماذا ارتبط الشعر
في الجزيره العربيه وحتى اشهر كبار
الشعراء العرب منذ القدم امرؤ القيس ولد
[موسيقى]
عذرا بس السؤال مره ثانيه لماذا ولد في
نجد يعني الشعر
لماذا ارتبط بالجزيره العربيه شو سر انه
بدا من هناك واشتهر والزهر من هناك
طبعا يعني الجزيره العربيه هي هي منبع كل
ثقافه عربيه لكن اذا بنتكلم عن عن عن
الشعر احنا سنتكلم عن
العربي نفسه الذي يعني روايه بدايه الشعر
هي روايات متعدده لكن في النهايه ما نعرفه
هو ان ان عرب الصحراء اكتشفوا هذا الشكل
من التعبير الفني
بشكله الشفاهي اولا
وشكله الانشادي يعني الى اليوم حينما يسال
الشاعر يعني لا يقال اقرا شعرا او او قل
لنا شعرا بل يقال انشد شعرا
فارتبط الشعر العربي اولا بالايقاع
وروايات كثيره يعني ما ودي ان اخذ من
وقتكم في قضيه كيف بدا الان اسئله كمان
شكرا جزيلا لك للاسف الشاعر عبد اللطيف بن
يوسف